こんにちは、私はOlivia Lanといって、IBM Quantumの研究者兼教育者だ。このビデオは
kkitのYouTubeチャンネルとラーニングプラットフォームで始まる全く新しいシリーズ「Quantum Computing in
Practice」のローンチを記念するものだ。要するに、このシリーズでは今まさに存在する量子コンピューターを最大限に
活用する方法を紹介する。量子コンピューターの将来の可能性や理論的なコンセプトについては、インターネット上にすでに何十億もの動画がある。
量子計算の背景にある理論も同様に重要だ。例えば、量子情報と計算を理解するには
John Watusがホストする講座を見るといい。ただしこのコースでは、受講者がこれまでより少し多くの知識を持っていることを前提とし、
技術的にかなり深いところまで踏み込む。なぜかというと、過去1年間、そしてこの録画時点、
つまり2024年において、計算の新しい時代への転換、いわば相転移が起きているからだ。
量子コンピューターはついに有用になりえるところに近づきつつある。小規模なcircuitや量子コンピューターでの実験は
コミュニティにこれらのマシンの使い方を教えるために必要だったが、通常の古典コンピューターでもできないような実験を誰も実行していなかった。しかし今日、私たちは
量子ユーティリティの時代に突入した。ユーティリティとは何かって？それはQuantum Advantageとは異なるもので、Quantum Advantageは
量子コンピューターが意味のあるタスクで古典コンピューターを上回る時点として理解できる。それに対しユーティリティとは、
両者が互いに競争し始められるということであり、これが技術的な
進化における自然な次のステップだ。IBMは昨年初めて、量子コンピューターを使って
物理モデルをシミュレートし、最先端の古典シミュレーション技術と競争できることを示した論文を発表した。さらにそれは
力任せの手法を上回り、研究者に研究で使える新たな道を切り開いた。では、なぜこれが今
起きているのか？ここ数ヶ月でIBMは100 qubitを超える量子プロセッサーを広く利用可能にした。もし
すでにユーザーなら、より大きなチップのために多くの小型プロセッサーを撤去したことに気づいているかもしれない。これは本当に
重要なことだと感じたからだ。なぜなら、ある数のqubitはまだ問題なく古典的にシミュレートできるため、
これらのチップを使っても実質的な優位性が得られない。しかし100 qubitになると、もはやそうではない。古典的に
シミュレートすることはできなくなる。また、シミュレーターと呼ばれるものが存在することも重要だ。
これらは本質的にコンピュータープログラムであり、ノイズを含む量子システムの一部の挙動を模倣できる。しかし
私が「模倣」と言ったことを見逃さないでほしい。シミュレーターは量子コンピューターではない。このスケールで量子コンピューターが出せるような結果は
出せない。ただし、テストのワークフローにおいては依然として重要な役割を担っている。以上、このスライドの冒頭の質問に対する
非常に長い回答だった。実践的な量子コンピューティングとは何か？このコースでは、Quantumの現実的な
潜在的なユースケースと、これらの大規模プロセッサーで実行・実験するためのベストプラクティスを教える。
では、このコースの対象者は誰か？レベル設定から始めよう。
最初に言っておくと、このコースは量子コンピューターの新しいアプリケーションを開発したいと思っているすべての人を対象としている。
現在の作業をスケールアップする方法を知りたい人や、既存のワークフローでQuantumを使う方法を学びたい人も対象だ。先ほど
このコースは非常に実践的で、理論的な側面はあまり扱わないと述べた。
量子計算とは何かについての基本的な理解を持って来てほしいが、まだそこに達していなくても心配しなくていい。
John Watersのコースの最初の数エピソードを見れば準備は整う。また、視聴者に知っておいてほしいのは、
これは物理学者やコンピューターサイエンティストだけのコースではないということだ。この2つの分野は
過去10年ほど量子コンピューティングを独占してきた。ビッグデータを扱う人や
シミュレーションに関わるエンジニア、化学者、材料科学者など、他の分野の人々にもこのコースが対象であることを知ってほしい。まとめると、
このコースは幅広い層を対象としており、全編を通して参加してくれることを願っている。このコースを修了すると、
ワークフロー全体を含め、kuitランタイムを通じてユーティリティスケールのジョブを作成・実行する方法を理解できるようになる。
主要なエラー軽減の種類を理解し、短期的な有望なアプリケーション領域も理解できるようになる。また、
これらのアルゴリズムをすべてkitで実行でき、最後にはノイズとその対処法を理解できるようになることを期待している。
では始めよう。量子コンピューティングは開発の初期段階にある刺激的な新技術だが、これは
数千年前に遡る計算の物語の一章に過ぎない。このコンテキストを理解することが重要だと思う。
なぜなら、私たちがここで目指していることが少し直感的で予測可能になり、
SFっぽさが薄れるからだ。古代から私たちは計算を行う必要があった。
つまり、一定のルールと制約に従って情報を処理することだ。これによって
コミュニケーション、建設、商業、科学、そして生活のあらゆる側面を可能にしてきた。私たちは物理世界に
助けを求め、独創的な発見を通じて計算を助けるデバイスを作ってきた。昔はデバイスが
木、骨、縄の結び目から作られ、今とはまったく異なる方法で情報を保存し計算を行っていた。
レバー、歯車、その他の機械から作られた機械装置は、初期の天文時計から
計算機へ、さらには車輪と回転ディスクを使って方程式を解く微分解析機などの高度な計算装置へと進歩した。
文字の技術でさえ、その物語において重要な役割を果たしてきた。それなしでは行えなかった
計算を人々が実行できるようにすることで。現代のコンピューターを考えるとき、私たちは
電子デジタルコンピューターを思い浮かべがちだが、これは実は比較的最近の技術だ。電子デジタルコンピューターが
最初に作られたのは1940年代だ。計算のために実際に使われた最も古いツールはシュメールのアバカスで、
専門家は紀元前2700〜2300年にバビロンで発明されたと考えている。本当に
ずいぶん昔の話だ。しかし私たちはArchimedesからEuclidを経て
Einsteinに至るまで、自然界についての理解を深めてきた。より多くの計算リソースへの需要は爆発的に増大した。現在私たちはスーパーコンピューターを持っており、
これは基本的に多数の非常に強力なコンピューターを並列につないだものだ。これらは人類が
難しい問題を解くための最良のツールの一つだ。しかしこれらの巨大コンピューターでさえ永遠に解けない問題はまだたくさんある。
これについては後で詳しく説明する。人間は物理学と自然を使って計算を助けてきたことが分かった。
それは数千年前から続いており、より多くより大きなものを計算したいという私たちの終わりなき探求を助けるために、あなたはすでに
知っているかもしれない。
ムーアの法則というのを知っているかもしれないが、実はこれは法則というよりも観察に近い。「法則」という部分はある意味
皮肉っぽい表現だと思う。集積回路、つまりコンピューターチップに搭載できるトランジスタの最大数が
約2年ごとに倍増するということだ。この約50年間、それを観察してきただけでなく、大いに活用してきた。
トランジスタが増えれば、より速く、より多くの計算ができる。これがコンピューターを
どんどん高性能化し、かつ小型化してきた主な要因だ。しかし残念なことに、ムーアの法則は終わりを迎えつつある。
ムーアの法則がいつ終わるかについては専門家の意見が分かれているが、すでに終わったという人もいる。もっとも、
限界がいつ来るかは正確にはわからなくても、それがいつか必然的に訪れることはわかっている。トランジスタの一部の部品は
物理的にこれ以上小さくできないからだ。例えば、原子より小さいトランジスタは作れない。これは
もちろん物理的にありえないことで、馬鹿げた話に聞こえるかもしれないが、それが現実に直面している限界だ。では
どうするのか？諦めて「これが限界だ」と言うのか？いや、人類はそんなことはしてこなかった。幸いなことに、量子
力学が登場した。量子力学は1920年代に発見され、それ以来、世界は
文字通り変わり続けてきた。その革命的な発見について何時間でも語れるが、
それはこのコースの焦点ではない。代わりに明確にしておきたいのは、量子
力学とコンピューティングはすでに互いに相性がいいということだ。量子力学から学んだ自然の理解は
部分的に現代のコンピューターを可能にしてきた。量子力学がなければ、
ソリッドステートハードドライブを理解することも、おそらく発明することもできなかっただろう。
例えばそういったことだ。量子コンピューティングは単に、この進化における次の自然なステップに過ぎない。
だが、計算は真空の中に存在するわけではない。情報には媒体が必要だ。
コンピューティングの情報は物理的な世界を利用し、それにも影響を与える。これが、物理的に可能なことに制限を課す。
しかし自然と物理的な限界を理解することは、まさに物理学という学問の目的だ。
ある意味で、物理学とコンピューティングは常に絡み合ってきた。コンピューター科学者でIBMの研究者でもあったRalph Landauerは
数十年前に「情報は物理的なものだ」と認識した。別の言い方をすれば、情報は
抽象的な存在ではなく、物理的な表現を通じてのみ存在する。Landauerの原理は情報と
熱力学の法則の間のつながりを確立した。しかし実際には、物理学と
コンピューティングの間には多くのつながりがある。古典物理学は最近まで探求できた全てだったが、量子
力学の発見によって、全く新しい計算方法を作り出せる瀬戸際に立っている。これは素晴らしいことだ。なぜなら
古典コンピューターは自然に実際に起こることを近似することしかできず、場合によってはその近似が非常に
限られているからだ。古典物理学の法則に従う機械に、
量子物理学の法則を近似させるのは本当に難しい。そして自然は古典的ではなく、量子的だ。理解を助けるかもしれない一つのアナロジーは
風洞だ。流体力学は数学的にシミュレートして予測するのが非常に難しいことで知られている。
風を受けて走る車のような平凡なことでさえもそうだ。自動車メーカーは、車を設計する際に
この物理的な相互作用をシミュレートしようとするのはコストがかかりすぎて現実的でないとわかった。代わりに
彼らが行ったのは、文字通り風を吹き込むトンネルを作り、そこに車を走らせる
ということだ。そしてどのように機能するか確かめる。これは、古典コンピューターが自然を
不十分にしか近似できないと言う意味のアナロジーだ。時にはそれを試みることさえコストがかかりすぎる。風をシミュレートする代わりに、
研究者はそれを再現する。同様に、量子コンピューターは自然の法則を
分子レベルで近似する必要がない。なぜならそれらの法則に本質的に従っているからだ。何かをシミュレートする必要はなく、エミュレートする。
同じ困難が電池や化学反応をシミュレートするときにも生じる。これが次のセクションにつながる。
量子コンピューティング、何の役に立つのか？
なぜ量子力学とコンピューティングを組み合わせることを考えるのか？すでに
最先端のスーパーコンピューターでも解決するには計算コストが高すぎる問題が十分にある。
それらは研究者だけが注目している問題かもしれないが、その影響は世界中の
あらゆる部分に及ぶ可能性がある。古典コンピューターが行き詰まるこれらの問題は、社会として私たちがますます
テクノロジーに依存し、本当に気にかけるようになっているもので、電池効率、金融モデリング、
最適化、さらにより優れた飛行機の設計なども含まれる。では量子コンピューターに目を向けるのはなぜか？非常に充分な理由がある。
ここには大きなポテンシャルがあると考えられており、現在最も強力なスーパーコンピューターでさえ手が届かない
新しい計算への扉を開ける可能性がある。理論的に、いくつかの量子アルゴリズムは
一部のアプリケーションに対して最良の古典アルゴリズムよりも優位性を提供する。他のアプリケーションでは、ノイズや不完全さがあっても
量子コンピューターが古典的なブルートフォース解法と競い合えるツールとして使えるという証拠が積み重なっている。
基本的に、これは全く新しいツールであり、それで何かもっとクールなことができないか探っている。しかし、
Feynmanの元々のアイデアに立ち戻ることもできる。それは物理学と自然そのものを理解するために使うということだ。
結局のところ、自然は量子的であり古典的ではないと既に言った。この分野は非常に豊かで魅力的で
学際的だ。物理学、コンピューター科学、情報処理、そしてもちろん私たちが興味を持つ特定の応用領域を結びつけている。
しかし古典コンピューターとは違い、全員がポケットに量子コンピューターを持っているわけではない。つい最近まで、量子コンピューターを試したいなら、
自分で組み立てて維持しなければならなかった。
普通は大学や研究施設のさびれた地下室のラボで。本当にそうだとわかる。しかし今はもう
そうではない。2016年、IBMが初めての量子プロセッサをクラウドに公開した。当時はわずか5 qubitしかなく、
エラー率もかなり高かったが、それはたった8年前のことで、どれだけ進歩したか見てほしい。では現在どこに立っているのか？
現代のコンピューターの黎明期との多くの類似点がある。前述のように、これは非常に
難しいチャレンジで、量子コンピューターが広く利用できるようになったのはたった8年前のことだ。Cutting edgeのラボや施設で
働いている人たちを除いてね。しかしその過去8年間で、あらゆる面で進歩を遂げてきた。
プロセッサーはqubitのサイズで桁違いに大きくなり、gateは大幅に改善され、新たな方法を導入した。
量子システムに固有のエラーを低減・軽減しながら、フォールト
トレラントな量子コンピューターの開発を進めている。今や誰でも、IBM Quantumの多数のプロセッサーを使えるようになっていて、
クラウド上でホストされているそれらのほぼすべてが、100以上の
qubitを持つ最新・最高のシステムだ。ただし重要なのはプロセッサーのサイズだけじゃない。これは私たちが気にする指標の一つに過ぎず、
それはもっともな話だ。qubitが多ければ明らかに有利だが、qubitの数を増やすことが
性能を低下させない場合に限る。しかしそれが常にそうとは限らない。互いに干渉しない
良質なqubitがもっと必要だ。不必要なクロストークによる干渉を避けるためだ。qubit同士がどのように接続されているかも重要で、超
伝導circuit ではqubitを物理的にどう接続するかが課題だ。もう一つの非常に重要な指標は
2-qubit gate Fidelityだ。シングルqubitで動作するgateはエラーが出にくいが、2-qubit gateははるかに
大きな問題領域であり、性能向上を確認するための代表的な指標の一つだ。
2-qubit gateを正確に動作させることは非常に重要で、qubit間のエンタングルメントを生成する役割を担っているからだ。
これが量子コンピューターに力を与える物理現象の一つだ。最後に速度と効率も求められる。
量子チップ上でプログラムを実行する時間が、できる限り迅速かつ効率的に
実行されることを確認しなければならない。これら3つの指標をまとめてスケール、品質、
スピードと呼ぶ。すべてが性能向上に不可欠だ。では、私がこれまで述べてきたことを裏付けるいくつかのグラフを見せよう。
技術自体が急速に進化していることがよくわかる。qubit数そのものが最もわかりやすい指標だと思うが、
IBMはqubit数とプロセッサーサイズの今後数年間のロードマップを公表している。
このビデオを撮影している2024年時点で、私たちはHeron と Condor というプロセッサーで予定通りに進んでいる。次に
品質について。このグラフはIBM Quantumプロセッサーの時系列での中央値エンタングリングgate エラーレートを示している。
これは対数スケールだという点に注意してほしい。進歩が漠然と線形に見えるが、実際にははるかに急速だ。
最後にスピードだ。このグラフはCLOPSと呼ぶ指標の進歩を示しており、これはcircuit layer
operations per secondの略だ。CLOPSはcircuitを実行するのにかかる時間と、必要なリアルタイムおよび
ニアタイムの古典的演算の両方を包括している。基本的にCLOPSは、プロセッサーが特定のcircuitを
連続して実行する速さを測る指標であり、量子と古典の
コンピューティングを統合したシステム全体の速度を表す。現在、録画時点ではIBMは100
qubit以上のマシンへのアクセスを提供している唯一の量子クラウドプロバイダーだ。先ほど述べた通り、100 qubitまたはその前後は古典的シミュレーションが
完全に限界に達し始めるところだ。そのため、これらのマシンで実行される大規模なジョブは古典的な等価手法が存在しないことが多い。
不可能なのだ。もちろんいくつかのニュアンスやテクニックがあって、circuitの一部をシミュレートし、他の
部分を別々にシミュレートすることも可能だ。しかし一般的に、この数値前後から量子コンピューターが古典コンピューターにはできないことをやり始められる、ということはわかっている。そこで
IBMはこれらの大型デバイスへのアクセスを広いコミュニティに提供することが非常に重要だと判断した。小さなデバイスで行われていることはすべて
古典的にシミュレート可能であり、量子優位性には繋がらないからだ。現在持っている100 qubit
デバイスはまだ欠陥があってノイズが多い。そのためジョブをどう実行するか賢く考える必要がある。
circuitをただ書いてShift+Enterを押すだけでは、おそらく何も
素晴らしいことは起きない。しかしここでも、実装できるテクニックやベストプラクティスがあり、これらのデバイスからさらに多くの
性能を引き出せる。それによって量子優位性が早まる可能性があり、フォールトトレラントマシンの構築も同時に続けながら
進めていける。このグラフは古典コンピューターと、エラー
軽減およびエラー訂正を備えた量子コンピューターで問題を解くのにかかる時間、つまりシミュレーションコストを示している。古典的計算の曲線はcircuitの複雑さが増すにつれて指数関数的に増加する。
ここにある単純なcircuitでは問題にならないが、複雑さが増すにつれて明らかに悪化する。
シミュレーションコストが非常に急速に高くなるからだ。エラー軽減はよりスケーリングが良好で、circuitの複雑さが増しても
そこに留まりたい。現在、古典的手法と量子的手法がいくつかのアプリケーションで
ほぼ同等になっている。エラー訂正は最も好ましくスケーリングも非常に良いが、
まだそこには達していない。当面はエラー軽減に注力し、できるだけ早くこの
量子ユーティリティの領域に到達することを目指す。そしてこのシリーズで学ぶいくつかのエラー軽減スキームを活用することで、
量子ユーティリティを近いうちに活用できるアプリケーション領域を見つけることを目指している。それこそが
このコースの核心だ。これらのマシンがあり、非常に興味深い研究ができると考えている。
ではどう使うか？エピソードのこの最後のセクションでは、実用的な量子コンピューティングの応用領域について簡単に話しよう。
私たちが最も探求したいと考えている主な3つの分野があり、量子
ユーティリティの道を見つけようとしている。最初は自然のシミュレーションだ。これは分子や原子の相互作用をシミュレートすることに関係しており、
材料科学や化学の分野で非常に重要だ。先ほど議論した理由から、量子
コンピューターは古典コンピューターよりもずっと優れていると考えている。次は探索と
最適化だ。ここで注目される主なアルゴリズムはQAOAと呼ばれる、古典と量子のハイブリッドアルゴリズムだ。QAOAは
古典コンピューターを使ってQuantum circuitの最適なパラメーターを訓練・探索し、どちらのコンピューター単体よりも
はるかに効率的に実行できると期待されている。最後は数学と構造を持つデータ処理だ。量子
コンピューターは、人間や典型的なコンピューターでは見えないような、雑然としたデータの中から構造を見つけることが非常に得意だ。
量子機械学習はこの分野で有望であり、特徴
抽出やパターン認識といったタスクへの活用を目指している。量子コンピューティングの分野で働く私たちにとって、本当に非常に刺激的な時代だ。
歴史上初めて、古典コンピューティングの限界を超えた計算領域を探求し始めることができる。
これを見ている皆さんは、もしかしたらコンピューティングの初期の先駆者たちと似た役割を
担うかもしれない。彼らはこの先に何が続くかまったく想像できていなかった。IBMのT.J. Watsonはかつて有名な言葉を残していて、コンピューターの市場は
たった2、3台分しかないだろうと考えていたという。そして彼はどれほど間違っていたことか。私たちは
みんな、コンピューティングの初期の先駆者たちだ。ただし量子コンピューティングというこの新しい分野での話だ。量子はよく
古典コンピューティングと対比されて、全く異なるものとして、あるいは競合するものとして語られる。しかし私が
この入門講義で目指したのは、俯瞰的な視点から見ると量子
コンピューティングが単純にコンピューティングの長い歴史における次の章として見なせるということを、皆さんに納得してもらうことだ。
新しい計算方法を探求し、自然界の力を活用し、それをどう使うかを考える——これは人間の本性だ。私たちはこれを
何世紀にもわたってやってきた。量子コンピューティングはこの探求における新しいツールを私たちに与えてくれる。それが提供してくれる
力をどう活かすかを発見するのは私たち次第だ。このシリーズの次のレッスンでは、100 qubitシステムについてもう少し詳しく話し、
Qiskit という量子ソフトウェアSDKの概要と、現時点でこれらのマシンとどう最適に
インタラクトするかについて説明する。ご視聴ありがとう。
次回もよろしく。